all right hello last time I spoke to you
you were new to the ground now you turn
into a little Instagram King yeah you've
got behind-the-scenes stuff of you and
your SWAT family are you guys really a
family yeah we are we are it's it's it's
really cool I've been in the game 26
years and and have you know young and
restless family Criminal Minds family
and now my new SWAT family and the
chemistry that you see on the screen is
real we don't have to fake it and you
know I've met a lot of good people in
Hollywood and I've met some jerks and by
being the lead of the show which I'm so
grateful for the opportunity I'm all
about like camaraderie and team and
family and no jerks on the set no jerks
and I said let's have fun and we do when
from up from from cut or not shooting
we're silly we're talking mess with
razzing each other
we're playing ping-pong we're throwing
footballs you know you're football pools
we're just we have a good time but when
you say action it's time to go everybody
whatever position you play actors
producers writers crew and we make it
happen but it's a the caskets along
really great the crew I mean we really
do it's a fun place to be we got to work
hard you spend 14 hours a day together
you know and it takes nine days to do
one episode so we see each other more
than we see our families and so but we
are really close-knit group and there's
a lot of episodes like one season is
like 30 something 20 20 22 to 24 this
year we're doing 23 I think it is it's
crazy yeah it's just ten and a half
months of our lives yeah so season three
was so excited back what can you tell us
about season three and are we getting
into any headlines because there's a lot
of things going on in the news that you
guys could tell you know you know what's
nice about SWAT and it's a lot of the
reason and I signed up is we are thrown
throw right first
when people hear that theme song they
know it's gonna be some action fact you
know craziness going on supercups and
here we come to save the day
but we do get topical and we do deal
with issues that are going on and then
sometimes we just have a good time and
just have some crazy bad guys that we
got to go chase down and it's fun to see
how we get it done so you are gonna see
our signature which I call our action it
was plenty of that I mean we we we feel
like a movie on television just the way
we shoot it and yeah the kind of things
that we do from helicopters car chases
blowing up buildings and flipping cars
and motorcycles aces and fights and all
that stuff but what I love about sois
does not only do we get topical but
we're also now that we're kind of we've
evolved the guns settled as a show we're
starting to get into backstories so it
was so we see who the characters are
behind I call it our GI Joe suit your
superhero suits but who we are as human
beings you know what makes us tick and
you know the the the the lights light
side of us and the darker sides of us
with Hondo in particular this year
you're gonna you're gonna really see a
lot of his family story and family
struggles you know of keeping bringing
back unity but mom and pops don't really
get along you know there's a history
there you're gonna learn more about mom
and pop I mean my father's played by
over Babatunde who is just he's a legend
I mean you just I mean I think I'm a
little bit talented but I can't I mean
I'm not even saying it cuz I'm on camera
I can't touch the man can sing the man
can dance the man can act it can do he
speaks like six languages
he's stupid funny and then just stupid
good man and so I get that I call it
when you when you can when you when you
when you do effortless acting it's
called you got a good dance partner so I
get to dance with over Debbie Allen you
know the legend
she plays my mom or me are you crazy you
know and then and then I've got two
sisters now you're gonna meet my older
sister that you've only heard about
Hondo probably am I supposed to say this
but Honda's got a little love interest
but she's making it hard on me though
he's up trust me she's making it hard I
mean the actresses actually Rochelle
Donna's here last name Rochelle eights
yeah yeah Rochelle eights I think it is
but she actually played my wife on
criminal
so they asked me you know thinking about
a love interest for you do you have any
more anybody mind I said you want to
know somebody who's real easy to look at
and can bring it
it's Rachelle and so they went through
the casting situation she got the gig
and so she's joined the show and she's
playing real hard to get though she's
making on to work but it's just fun
because you're gonna because you know
Hondo is is the leader he's so serious
he's a badass he's an ex-marine he's got
a lot of pressure on him he's got to
lead this team he kicks ass and takes
down bad guys you know and and that's
fun but you but but you also want to see
the human side of them yeah so that's
what the family elements gonna bring and
then you'll see some charm I know you'll
get to see how it'll smile a little more
with with the love interest and with
family so there's a nice balance
so it's edgy edgy you see thrill ride
with topics and humanity and then the
characters being more humanized mm-hmm I
know you said on Instagram Hondo's voice
you were a bit rusty how to get it back
no Honda Honda Honda shamar's gmarks
baby girl what's good that's good gotta
get my drink is right and in the next I
know on the host I'm to 20 David's
command do you use your Honda voice for
things outside of swap like are you just
out here using in the street no no you
know I honestly I just keep it for the
show and it's it's not it just be kind
of became a Hondo voice I was just I was
just acting doing my thing and then I
heard I don't know if it's something
they do with the mics on the show
there's something because I was watching
it my and I like I have a TV room and
have pretty big speakers and you know 16
years TV or whatever and the show came
on and every time I talk to my walls
would Rumble and it was a rule I was
like I was there and my friends were
like you know boys ain't that deep you
know I was like yes it is when they said
action to cut I'm a bad man you know I
started doing that and so and you know
outside of SWAT I like maybe when I'm
talking mess when I'm talking mess I
might go in tomorrow voice me you don't
mess with me baby you don't miss you
know hey baby girl
do you WI do that oh yeah always for the
baby girls always the baby girls but no
songs but I did find myself depending on
the situation yeah I find when I get
serious it's not something like I try to
do I just just could become instinctive
now so it's you know I just get into my
own door situation and I start and I
just think it makes it give it gravitas
if you take them a little more seriously
it's a little more intimidating yeah and
so it's just a voice I found um the
people want to know people want to know
final season Criminal Minds hmm are you
going to be on it is it in your calendar
is there an email about it is anyone
texted you what's the team at the final
season of Criminal Minds has already
been shot so the actors are chilling
enjoying all their money on vacation
maybe looking for a new gig whatever but
there is a final season 15 that'll play
out sometime this coming season um but
if I can tell the truth I think there
was schedule conflicts because being
Hondo takes up most of my time so I did
get to come back a couple of times after
I left Swat to check in with my baby
girl and excuse me and Pretty Ricky play
I called Pretty Ricky which is dr. Reed
Matthew Gray Gubler but no the I just I
don't think they were I don't think they
I don't think the schedules messed up
for me to come back but for the fans out
there
I completely wanted to be a part of it
because it was it truly was such a huge
part of my life and career and might as
we were talking about family that that
was my my first family was was young and
restless my second and two and you never
forget where you come from and I'll
never forget young and restless and may
he rest in peace my dear friend Kristoff
st. John I'll never forget Criminal
Minds and now I'm having a good time
with my new family on squad yeah so 2020
is coming up you have a milestone
birthday yeah man don't do we have to
talk about that
yeah I'm trying I'm trying GU black
don't crack big butter cocoa butter and
baby oil
[Laughter]
you celebrate or you claim my friends
are like you what we gonna do for five
Oh what we got I said how about we don't
talk about it you know it's just what
you know when I was in high school well
like when I was like a freshman or
sophomore some of the seniors had beards
they looked like grown grown men and and
so I was like wow and then you thought
of like 40 like it was the end it was
the end like oh when you hit 40 like
life is you're done yeah just your
oldest dirt and Here I am you know 49 I
actually I actually feel great and I
like I like myself getting older um I
like I like how I feel I like I like the
wisdom I like the life experience I like
that I feel really comfortable in my
skin
so it's more about a feeling than it is
a number so as long as I feel good and
not try my best to stay in shape and I'm
good so I don't know I don't know what
50 will be it'll I mean it'll be some
type of party I'm you know I'd love to
travel
I'd love to travel so you know every
every year I've been to pick in a
different country and going exploring
that kind of thing